reden wir drüber mit einem mann der von
verkehrspolitik wirklich null ahnung hat
aber das hat uns noch nie abgehalten mit
olaf schubert
[Musik]
ja und ich habe es gerade gesagt ist
drohen fahrverbote wie hast du dieses
urteil vom dienstag aufgenommen gefasst
denn ich habe bisher auch kaum sehen
machen wir uns nichts wo autos zu bauen
das war noch nie sache der deutschen
na ja man hat das steht natürlich
irgendwie geduldet aber die politik
hätte die autobauer unterstützen können
müssen finanziell auch strukturell indem
man autofahren attraktiv macht das ist
nicht geschehen
es gibt immer noch straßen mit
tempolimit gerade in der stadt ja und
jetzt fahrverbote das heißt also dass
massenhaft deutsche diesel abrupt zum
stehen kommen und das ist gab es nur
einmal bis jetzt also kurz vor
stalingrad gerade die handwerksbetriebe
gerade die handwerker sehen sich in
ihrer existenz bedroht war zu lesen
kannst das nachvollziehen wer hat da
frage ich mich warum kaufen handwerker
immer so langweilig diesel transporter
und nicht mal irgendwie ein maserati
pickup mit bentley pritsche also
irgendwas flottes dann würden sie auch
nicht mehr ständig zu entwickeln
aber man muss auch sagen für mich ist
nicht der leidtragende der besitzer des
vw golf zwölf jahre alt vierte hand ich
meine wo kein wert kein wertverlust
sondern derjenige der ein puzzle cayenne
turbo diesel sich ver munde abgespart
hat über wochen
der hat jetzt ein wertverlust von 100000
euro
und ich habe drei von den kisten wir
sammeln
es muss ja
es muss ja irgendeine art umdenken statt
schön aber umfragen sagen viele deutsche
fremdeln immer noch mit öffentlichen
personennahverkehr
was könnte man tun ist das mit den
kostenlosen bussen und bahnen wäre das
die lösung
das kostet das wäre mir neu also man
merkt ich habe kein problem mit
öffentlichen personennahverkehr ich habe
nur ein problem mit denen ich mitfahren
also das ja ja dann muss man sagen dass
ich da wirklich es ist stellenweise
bevölkerung will dass die leute ich
meine die im studio gehen aber da ja
jetzt erkältungszeit du bist ja sofort
infiziert hat er genügt blickkontakt
dann auch sehr erschwerend diese hohen
zu spiegel
das heißt du bekommst das auto ganz
schlecht rhein und die die völlige
flexibilität auch beim personal neulich
der andere an der haltestelle bin ich
zum straßenbahnfahrer hat gesagt hier
ich hab was zu tun das war mal eine
halbe stunde warten da guckt er mich an
stumpf und fährt einfach los also
elementarste serviceleistungen werden
nicht erbracht danone werden mit füßen
getreten
dein tipp stirbt er diese jetzt aus der
dürfen
er stirbt die gute nachricht ist er
stirbt erst nach der menschheit
bis dahin brauchen wir den dieses jahr
ist unverzichtbar muss man einfach sagen
denn das größte risiko ist ja nicht das
stickoxid und wir wissen ist der
feinstaub und der entsteht nicht durch
den diesel sondern durch reifenabrieb
bremst verschleiß ja das ist so große
reibungen wirken da entsteht das nennt
das haben eben auch beim fahrrad oder
beim einsatz
natürlich auch beim kondom
das ist elementar
alle hier
wir müssen uns darüber im klaren sein
nein zum diesel sagt sagt auch nein zur
landwirtschaftlichen nutzfahrzeugen er
sagt nein zur schifffahrt und dann kann
ich mich dann nicht mehr ins
stadtzentrum von bottrop
und da ja das sage ich danke merkel ich
auch olaf schuberts dankeschön
[Applaus]